im Oktober 2022 ist es passiert eine nie
dagewesenes politisches Erdbeben
erschütterte Italien Georgia Melone die
Kandidatin der Partei fratellite Italia
hat die Wahlen gewonnen während ihrer
Partei bei den Wahlen von 2018 nur 4,4
Prozent der Stimme erhielt als sie
dieses Mal die Unterstützung von fast
26% der Wähler gewonnen
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier also geradezu von
einem Erdrutsch Sieg für eine Partei die
erst 2012 gegründet wurde und wir
sprechen auch von einem Ergebnis dass
sie an die Spitze der Mitte
rechtskoalition gebracht hat die jetzt
Italien regiert melonis Partei trat ein
Wahl den Bündnis mit leger und
berufsporter Italia an zusammen gewann
sich fast 60% der Sitze in der
Abgeordnetenkammer und in seiner Art
und wie ihr vielleicht schon mitbekommen
habt sollte dieser Kurswechsel in der
drittgrößten Volkswirtschaft Europas für
viel Gesprächsstoff ja gerade so für
Panik vor allem weil es heißt das
Italien mit der Wahl melonis in die
Hände Neo faschistische rechter gefallen
sei aber die Frage ist stimmt das
besteht Grund zur Besorgnis in diesem
Video erklären wir euch zuerst die
Schlüsselfaktoren für melonie Sieg und
beantworten dann eine entscheidende
Frage was können wir jetzt von Italien
erwarten heute werden wir diese für ganz
Europa brennende Frage natürlich
beantworten aber bevor wir total
streiten möchte ich euch ein spannendes
Spiel unseres Sponsors Gold Games
vorstellen dass nicht nur mit perfekter
3D Grafik daher kommt sondern unter den
vielen Online wenn sie Rollenspielen in
einer sehr interessanten Idee heraus
liegt bloodline heroes of leasers denn
über die Genre üblichen Elemente wieder
sammeln und Trainieren von Helden mit
denen du dann in den Kampf triffst steht
im Zentrum seines Gameplays eine
originelle und interessante umgesetzte
Spielmechanik ein paarungs- und
vererbungssystem ja du hast richtig
gehört du kannst die verschiedenen Blatt
wie helfen Dämonen Halbgötter
Drachen geboren und Vampire miteinander
schnackseln lassen ihre süßen Babys
werden dann die Kombination der
Eigenschaften ihrer Eltern und je besser
diese zueinander passen desto stärker
schämst zeugen sie für dich daraus
kannst du dir über viele Generationen
riesige familienbäume heranzüchten bist
du die für deine herstelldynastie
optimalen fähigkeitskombination gefunden
hast um dein mächtiges Königreich
aufzubauen jeden Monat werden neue
Blutlinie veröffentlicht also hast Du
unendlich viele Möglichkeiten den besten
Hybriden zu finden der zu deinem
Spielstil passt Ende 2022 kommt zum
Beispiel zwei Blumen ins Spiel die
stärksten Tanks und der Fuchs ähnliche
vulpin-clan das sind die schnellsten
Assassinen so und wenn du ab 24 November
anfängst gewinnt eventuell nimmst
erhältst du einen mit Taurus Champion
kostenlos und das ist noch nicht alles
denn wenn du den Link in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video benutzt
oder nicht auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt
oder hast du meine exklusives Starter
Pack in Wert von 20 $, das enthält drei
ausdauertränke 100.000 Gold und 100
Diamanten zögert also wie gesagt nur um
24 November 2022 gibt es den kostenlosen
Minotaurus Champion als Thanksgiving
Geschenk ihr werdet sehen es lohnt sich
wirklich dieses innovative free to play
RPG anzuspielen das Spiel enthält war
später leichte petube progress-elemente
aber es handelt sich nicht um ein pay to
win Game man kann auch ohne echtes Geld
vorankommen und viel Spaß haben vergesst
bitte nicht dass ihr mit eurem
Probespielen auch uns finanzielle
unterstützt euch kostet es nichts aber
uns helft ihr diese Videos zu
finanzieren helfen könnt ihr uns
übrigens auch direkt Hilfe des Spenden
links den ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung bei den damit
hättet ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr
und noch bessere Videos zu liefern so
und nun lasst uns keine Zeit
verschwenden und schnell nach Bella
Italia Reisen einem Land in dem es
politisch drunter und drüber geht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie alla familia natural no alles
sexual no alé lackieren
[Musik]
Problemo vorstellen könnt haben diese
und ähnliche Aussagen Deutschland
stehen und es geht nicht nur darum was
sie sagt sondern auch darum wie sie es
sagt der Ton spielt an Zeiten an die uns
verdammt düster in Erinnerung sind ihre
Rhetorik ist astreiner Populismus und
gleitet oft genug in die Agitation ab
das ist natürlich bezeichnen und zeigt
in gewissen gerade schon wessen
geisteskind ihr vor uns haben aber das
ist nicht alles Meloni ist mehr als das
wenn wir wissen wollen warum sie
gewonnen hat und was wir jetzt erwarten
können müssen wir ein bisschen tiefer
Graben und da gibt es weniger
mysteriöses als die Rede vom rechten
schreckengespenster vermuten lässt denn
das scheinbar neue politische und
soziale Phänomen hinter der Melone ist
gar nicht mal so neu und auch sie selbst
ist wieder eine politische Außenseiterin
noch ein neulich im Gegenteil Meloni
weiß sehr genau was sie tut und kann
sich auf Erfahrungswerte aus der
Vergangenheit Stützen teils aus anderen
Ländern teils aber auch aus ihrer
eigenen Laufbahn denn ganz nur im
Geschäft ist sie nicht
Melodie war als Teenagerin in
politischen Studentenbewegungen aktiv
das ist ihre viel beschworene Verbindung
zum italienischen post Tourismus 2006
wurde sie zum ersten Mal für die Partei
nationale Allianz ins italienische
Parlament gewählt im Jahr 2008 gerade
mal im Alter von 21 Jahren wurde sie
dann von Silvio bei uns chronito
jugendministerin ernannt und war damit
die jüngste Ministerin in der Geschichte
des Landes sie hatte dieses Amt bis Ende
2011 inmitten einer großen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Krise zum
Rücktritt gezwungen wurde ein Jahr
später gründete Melone ihre eigene
Partei die fratellit Italia zu deutsch
die Brüder Italiens wie der Name schon
anzeigt eine tatsächlich im üblichen
Schema ziemlich weit rechts einzuordnen
sind Partei die zudem auch deutlich
weiter rechts steht als melonis alte
Partei der los Kunis Forza Italia
ideologische Ähnlichkeit hat sie eher
mit
matthäuser dazu gehört unter anderem der
Schafe eurospizismus den die Partei ist
vor kurzem vertreten haben
und vielleicht ist deshalb klar dass
diese Sieg beim Brüssel nicht gut
ankommt
auf europäischer Ebene sind beloni und
ihre fratelliparkeit Teil der Fraktion
der Europäischen konservativen und
Reformisten in der Parteien wie die
polnische PS VOX aus Spanien und die
Schweden Demokraten zusammengeschlossen
sind das erklärt auch warum Brüssel eine
gewisse Angst davor hat dass die
drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Union
eine ähnlich feindselige oder
ungehorsame Haltung einnehmen könnte wie
zum Beispiel Ungarn oder Polen das und
die wagenverbindungen zum postfaschismus
haben zudem alle medialen Alarmglocken
lassen und die wo viele Medienvertreter
entfacht geradezu eine mediale
Dampfwalze
Georgia Meloni und die Rückkehr des
Faschismus wie es in Italien soweit
kommen konnte die rechtsextreme John
Germany zeigt den Busch der Italiener
nach radikale
Manni ist eine Gefahr für Italien und
den Rest Europas Meloni fragt das liegt
ihrer neofaschistischen politischen
Vorfahren mit dem Slogan Gott
heimatfamilie aus der Mussolini Ehra wie
ihr seht gibt es viele die den Sieg von
Georgia Meloni als eine Art Sieg ist Neo
Faschismus dargestellt haben es macht
Übernahme durch die extreme Rechte und
in einer solchen Situation fragen sich
natürlich viele von euch ist der
Faschismus wirklich nach Italien
zurückgekehrt ist Georgia Meloni sie
eine Bedrohung für die Demokratie was
könnte ihr Sieg für das Land von
Valentino Rossi Enzo Ferrari und Giorgio
Armani bedeuten all diese Fragen werden
wir heute ausführlich beantworten also
spitzt die Ohren
ein kompliziertes Erbe
[Musik]
liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer machen wir
uns nichts vor nichts geschieht ohne
Grund und auch der Wahl sieht melonis
war kein Zufall die Italiener hatten
ihre Gründe
[Musik]
Italien bei den letzten zwei Jahrzehnten
eines der Länder mit der schlechtesten
Wirtschaftsleistung in der gesamten
entwickelten Welt das reale pro Gruppe
war 2019 niedriger als im Jahr 2000 die
Staatsverschuldung liegt bei rund 145%
BIP und ist damit nach Griechenland die
zweitgrößte in der Eurozone und die fünf
höchste weltweit außerdem belasten die
immer noch relativ geringe Integration
von Frauen in den Arbeitsmarkt oder
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit weiterhin die
Wirtschaft die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit
liegt seit Jahren über 20% zu all dem
kommt in letzter Zeit dann auch noch die
hohe Inflation und das alles bei einer
relativen Defizite von mehr als 5%
schwachen Wachstum und düsteren
Zukunftsprognosen
[Musik]
tatsächlich werden wir bald ein Video
mit weiteren Details zu italienischen
Wirtschaft auf unserem Schwester Kanal
bist du alle economic veröffentlichen
schaut dort doch gleich nach diesem
Video mal vorbei den Link dorthin findet
ihr in der Videobeschreibung denn wenn
euch visualpolitik gefällt wird euch
sicher auch visual economic gefallen
aber zurück zum Thema
[Musik]
denn Tatsache ist wenn sich die Dinge
nicht ändern steuert Italien mit voll
Dampf auf eine praktisch garantierten
bankrot zu die ersten Auswirkungen
dieser Entwicklung bekommen die
Italiener schon zu spüren der
Lebensstandard hat sich dort seit vielen
Jahren nicht mehr verbessert um aus dem
Loch herauszukommen braucht Italien also
eine echte wirtschaftliche
regulatorische und steuerliche
Revolution unter anderem muss das Land
dafür radikal seine Ausgaben
einschränken man lebt dort schon seit
Jahren deutlich über seinen
Verhältnissen heute schon ist der
einzige relevante Akteur der noch
italienische Staatsschulden kauft die
Europäische Zentralbank aber in einem
Land in denen die Politik alle paar
Jahre Bruchlandungen erleidet um wieder
neu anzufangen scheint ein solcher
Wechsel nicht machbar zu sein
und diese Instabilität wirkt sich
natürlich auch auf die Wirtschaft aus
schließlich reden wir über ein Land das
in den letzten 77 Jahren von 70
Regierungen geführt wurde bei so viel
politischer Unbeständigkeit gibt es
keine Möglichkeit einen Mittel- oder
langfristigen Reformplan umzusetzen komm
mal eine Regierung etwas angefangen da
dauert es oft kaum ein Jahr und die
nächste schmeißt wieder alles über den
Haufen und das macht natürlich auch
etwas mit den Wählern das ganze Hin und
Her hat so eine enormen des
illusionierung unter den Italienern
geführt die sehen das ist ihrem Land von
Jahr zu Jahr schlechter geht in Italien
sind sich die Politiker praktisch nur in
einem einzigen Punkt eilig ihre massive
Nutzung der öffentlichen Kreditkarte um
sich mit Geschenken Stimmen zu kaufen so
erklärt sich auch eine der wenigen
Kontinuitäten in der italienischen
Regierungsarbeit die kontinuierliche
Erhöhung der Renten und die verschlingen
schon jetzt mehr als 16 % des gesamten
BIP oder wie wäre es mit diesem Beispiel
Italien hat bisher mehr als 66
Milliarden Euro an Hilfen ausgegeben um
die Auswirkungen der Energiekrise zu
lindern ob das richtig oder falsch ist
weil da hingestellt klar aber scheint
was man diese Hilfen nicht lange
durchhalten wird wenn also alles klar
ist dann dass die Wirtschaftspolitik
eine der größten Herausforderungen für
die neue Regierung Meloni sein wird
neben vielen wahlgeschenken hat der
Melone hier auch einige Lösungskonzepte
während des Wahlkampfs anzubieten aber
zu dem Versprechungen kommen wir im
zweiten Teil dieses Videos denn die
wirtschaftliche Misere des Landes war
ein wichtiger Faktor für den Sieg
belonies aber nicht der einzige
da wäre zum Beispiel das Thema illegale
Einwanderung in ganz Europa eines der
heißesten Themen aber in Italien ganz
besonders um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben seit 2015 sind 750.000 illegale
Einwanderer in Italien angekommen allein
im August 2022 kam mir mehr als 45.600
Menschen erikulär an den italienischen
Umfang an das war ein Anstieg von 40% im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr
natürlich ein Thema auf das ich Melone
im Wahlkampf gestürzt hat was ihr die
Sache aber besonders leicht gemacht hat
von allen Menschen die im August 2022
illegal an den italienischen Küsten
ankamen hat dies fast die Hälfte an Bord
von ngo-booten oder von Schiffen der
italienischen Marine selbst dieses
brodelnde Gemisch aus stoßenlosigkeit
schlechter Wirtschaftslage Pessimismus
Einwanderung oder Zunahme von Gewalt
erklärte melonis die schon ziemlich gut
man kann also sagen die Italiener sind
sich einfach nach einer neuen und klaren
Linie in der Politik und da war eine
lunis Partei eine noch unverbrauchte
macht die scheinbar Lösungen für viele
der Probleme bereit hielt dabei dürfte
Meloni übrigens besonders gut geholfen
haben dass sie die einzige relevante
Partei für die nicht am vorherigen
Regierungsbündnis unter Mario Draghi
beteiligt war denn obwohl Draghi sehr
beliebt ist gehört er selbst doch keiner
Partei an die Parteien unter ihm sind
heilungs zerstritten gewesen und haben
also die erstbeste Gelegenheit genutzt
um Neuwahlen zu produzieren melonis
pratelli Vitalia konnten derweil
genüsslich auf der Oppositionsbank
sitzen und zusehen wie die anderen Ihnen
die Wähler in die Arme Betrieben dazu
kam noch dass die linken Parteien durch
diesen Wahlkampf ist nicht schafften ein
stabiles ballbündnis als Gegengewicht zu
den Rechten untermelone zu bilden gut so
viel also zu den Gründen des Siegs
melonis und ihres Wahlbündnisses die
Frage ist jetzt was wir von diesen neuen
politischen Phänomen in Italien erwarten
können also lasst uns das jetzt mal
näher untersuchen
die Geburt einer Melodie Mani
fangen wir wieder mit der Wirtschaft an
melonis Haltung könnte man hier irgendwo
auf halben Wege zwischen Protektionismus
und Wirtschaftsliberalismus verorten
insofern das überhaupt eine kompatible
Mischung darstellt und wir hier nicht
schon den ersten Widerspruch haben lass
mich also versuchen diese Haltung
aufzuschlüsseln in Melone ist
patriotischer Wirtschaft Agenda gibt es
Maßnahmen für jeden Geschmack wir hätten
da populistische nationalistische sowie
protektionistische Formeln und dann
werden da noch ein paar interessante
Ideen
einerseits befürwortet Meloni Maßnahmen
gegen den freien Markt dadurch soll
verhindert werden dass bestimmte
ausländische Produkte eingeführt werden
und das ausländische Unternehmen
Mehrheitsbeteiligung an strategisch
wichtigen italienischen Unternehmen
erlangen ein Beispiel dafür ist der
Widerstand gegen die Übernahme der
nationalen Fluggesellschaft ita Airways
durch Air France Meloni möchte auch dass
der Stadt öffentliche Finanzinstitute
nutzt um große italienische Unternehmen
zu kontrollieren das ist der Fall bei
Telekom Italien
telekommunikationskolaus den Meloni
wieder verstaatlichen und direkt
verwalten will
das alles sind Tendenzen die wir bisher
eher vom interventionistischen Nachbarn
in Italien aus Frankreich 7 juli 2022
Frankreich verstaatlicht Europas größtes
Stromunternehmen und erwartet die
unvermeidliche Rückkehr des Staates aber
lassen Sie uns nicht ablenken
[Musik]
eines von melonis wichtigsten
versprechen war eine allgemeine
Steuersenkung für Familien und
Unternehmen da stellt sich die Frage wie
kann die italienische Regierung
angesichts des katastrophalen
öffentlichen Haushalts große
Steuersenkungen durchsetzen tja das ist
eine wichtige Frage die noch geklärt
werden muss trotz der Tatsache dass ihr
erster Haushalt wohl mehr Ausgaben in
Höhe von 30 Milliarden Euro beinhalten
wird will man trotzdem doch etwas gegen
finanzieren aus Melone ist inneren Kreis
wurde etwa der Vorschlag laut das
sogenannte Bürgergeld abzuschaffen diese
staatliche Leistung ist ein Art
garantiertes mindestens Einkommen für
Arbeitslose das unter fünf Sterne
Bewegung im Wahlkampf 2018 gefordert
wurde es handelt sich dabei um eine
Beihilfe zwischen 500 und 780 € pro
Monat ein Programm das sich besonders im
wirtschaftlich relativ schwaches
Süditalien großer beliebter erfreute
dort leben ca 70% der begünstigt das
Problem damit ist nur dieses Bürgergeld
ist zwar teuer besprechen über knapp 9
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr doch das reicht
kurzfristig nicht um die Steuersenkungen
gegen zu finanzieren aber es stehen noch
weitere Optionen im Raum eine davon hat
Millionen selbst steuerfrieden getauft
eine Art steueramlistie mit der man oft
in fünf Jahren etwa 30 Milliarden Euro
mehr einzunehmen und was soll dieser
steuerfrieden genau darstellen
nun Meloni meint damit eine Maßnahme die
seit mehr als 20 Jahren in politischen
Debatten herumgeistert bisher nie
umgesetzt wurde die Rede ist von der
sogenannten flatex konkret hat sich das
Wahlbündnis unter Meloni darauf geeinigt
einen einheitlichen Steuersatz
einzuführen wer so zunächst für
Selbstständige gelten die bis zu 100.000
€ im Jahr einnehmen in späteren Phasen
soll das Konzept dann auf die jährlichen
Einkommenssteigerungen aller
Steuerzahler ausgeweitet werden mit
anderen Worten wenn es einer schafft
mehr zu verdienen wird im ersten Jahr
dafür fiskalisch belohnt eine
klassischer Traum liberaler
fiskalpolitiker und
Finanzwissenschaftler hinzukommen auch
wenn das System ganz umgesetzt würde
wäre das nicht nur ein steuerlicher
Vorteil für abgehoben und ähnliche
Konsorten sondern ganz besonders für
Familien denn umso größer eine Familie
wird desto mehr Steuervergünstigung
erhält sie eben ganz nach dem Motto Gott
Heimat und Familie was die Unternehmen
angeht so hat melonis Team versprochen
sich für starke Steuerabzüge einzusetzen
wenn ein Unternehmen mehr Arbeitskräfte
einstellt hier soll das Prinzip gelten
wer die meisten einstellt zahlt am
wenigsten
[Musik]
aber alles schön und gut kurzfristig
hilft das nicht das Haushaltsloch zu
stopfen ich im Gegenteil und auch
langfristig ist die Sache eine riskantes
Spiel denn was wenn die Steuersenkung
nicht durch wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung
und eine schlanke Bürokratie
überkompliziert wird eine abschließende
Antwort auf die wirtschaftlichen
Probleme Italiens hat beloni also
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich zu
bieten aber so ist das nun mal in der
Politik versprochen ist vieles schnell
ob es gehalten wird werden wir sehen und
auch erstmal abwarten ob es die
Legislaturperiode überhaupt übersteht um
den wirtschaftlichen Teil abzuschließen
hier gibt es noch eine besondere
Herausforderung welche die neue
Regierung von ihrer Vorgängerin
übernimmt ich spreche vom sogenannten
national recover
[Musik]
dieser Plan ist im Grunde Italiens
Fahrplan für die Zugang zu den
europäischen next generation Force
aufgrund des Verhandlungsgeschicks des
alten Ministerpräsidenten Draghi werden
Italien aus diesem Fonds und 200
Milliarden Euro zugewiesen dieser Planet
im Wahlkampf viel Aufsehen Erik weil
Melone darauf bestanden hat ihn von
Grund auch zu ändern ihr Ziel ist es
sicher grüne Politik bereiten und mehr
Mittel für die Durchführung von
Großprojekten zu verwenden zu diesem
gehört zum Beispiel die Brücke über die
Straße von Messina welches Ziel mit dem
Festland verbinden würde sie wäre die
längste Hängebrücke der Welt
nun ja wir werden sehen wie das alles in
Brüssel ankommt gut so viel aber nun
wirklich zum wirtschaftlichen Teil denn
wenn eines klar ist dann dass die
Auswirkungen des Phänomens Meloni weit
über die Wirtschaft hinausgehen
aufgepasst manuell macron ich hätte
definitiv
[Musik]
[Applaus]
a
[Musik]
polnisch oder ungarisch
tja die Achse Paris Berlin als Zentrale
schrittenzieren in der EU ist Meloni
offenbar eine echter Donner im Auge
Europa gegen Europa unser Europa das
griechische christliche Wurzeln hat
gegen das Europa von macron und Merkel
ein Europa von denen die immer mehr
nationale Souveränität an die
Technokraten der EU abgeben wollen
aber mit macron fliegt sie ein besonders
liebevolles Verhältnis
[Musik]
Ecki kommila francha continua astrutare
la Fricka
[Applaus]
Übersetzer elektrischer
ist Meloni ein populistischer Anführer
auf jeden Fall ist sie eine Politikerin
die radikalere Position vertritt als
normalerweise üblich zweifellos ist die
konservativ sicherlich nationalistisch
tja auch das aber inwiefern eigentlich
und was bedeutet das alles denn sie
zugleich als Bedrohung für die
Demokratie zu deklarieren ist noch mal
ein großer Sprung und eine schwere
Anschuldigung versuchen wir doch einen
griffigen Zugang zu der Sache zu finden
angesichts der ideologischen
Ähnlichkeiten in vielen Bereichen liegt
dazu folgende Frage nahe ist Melone eher
wie ungarnitekt geben
nun nehmen wir doch eine der großen
Konflikte der letzten Jahre als Referenz
den Krieg in der Ukraine und die
Stellung des Westens zu ihm achtet mal
auf diese Aussagen
we are on the side of freedom Andy we
are on the side of proud nation that is
teaching
for freedom
vereinfachen denke ich dass ich davon
überzeugt bin dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine die Spitze des Eisbergs eines
Konfliktes bildetes Ziel die Revision
der Weltordnung ist wenn die Ukraine
fällt wenn der besten Schwäche zeigt
wird neben Putin Russland auch China
also den großen Gewinnern des Konflikt
gehören nur weil es ein paar Leute gab
die meinten dass Meloni Sieg ein Sieg
Putin sein Sohn Meloni als auch ihre
Partei die Italia haben an ihrem
Eintreten für die NATO und der
Verteidigung der Ukraine in letzter Zeit
keinen Zweifel mehr gelassen
[Musik]
unter anderem treten sie dafür ein die
Waffenlieferungen an Kiew zu erhöhen das
war sogar einer der außenpolitischen
Stützpfeiler während des Wahlkampfs
jemand könnte sogar sagen die oberste
Priorität des Wahlprogramms der
Koalition und das obwohl Melone ist
Mitstreiter im Wahlbündnis Albini und
beruskonig durchaus sympathisierende
Töne Richtung Moskau sendet 23 September
2022 Berlusconi meint Putin sei in die
Ukraine eingedrungen um anständige Leute
in Kiew einzusetzen erster juni 2022
Italien Salvini unter Beschuss wegen
geheime Gespräche mit Russland Treffen
mit dem Botschafter sollen vom
Parlamentsausschuss untersucht werden
aber wie wir inzwischen wissen es ist
Melodie zumindest bisher trotzdem
gelungen ihre pronator und prokraine und
pro us-vision durchzusetzen ihre
Position gegenüber der EU ist hingegen
ambivalenter lange zeigte sich hier sehr
skeptisch und forderte in der
Vergangenheit sogar den Austritt
Italiens aus der Union einen italexit
solche Töne sind inzwischen nicht mehr
von ihr zu hören wahrscheinlich ist sie
sich darüber klar geworden dass Italien
sich dafür schon viel zu abhängig der EU
gemacht hat ein Auszeit würde
höchstwahrscheinlich einen Staatsbank
rund und eine massive Rezession nach
sich ziehen nicht nur weil Italien am
finanziellen Prof der EZB hängt sondern
auch wegen anderen wirtschaftlichen
Verpflichtungen Italiens Wirtschaft wäre
ohne die unionsstützen wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig dank der
durch den Währungsraum verzerrten
Inflation und die durch den großen
Binnenmarkt und die zentrale Absicherung
über die EZB induzierte fehlalokation am
Arbeitsmarkt also haben die fratelli
inzwischen ein deutlich pragmatischeren
Plan vorgelegt
[Musik]
Meloni hat eingeräumt das Italien nicht
in der Lage ist die Union zu verlassen
und das ist wirtschaftliche Hilfe von
ihren Institutionen braucht um den
bankrot zu vermeiden aus diesem Grund
beschränkt sich die italienische Politik
inzwischen auch Forderungen und nach
Reformen in Brüssel dennoch bleibt eine
gewisse durchaus bestehen konkret
vertritt Meloni eine Position die man
unter dem Schlagwort schaltest vom
Europa der Vaterländer zusammenfassen
könnte damit steht Italien nun der
Position der polnischen Regierung hat
dort möchte man vor allem dass die
europäischen Strukturen weniger
zentralisiert und bürokratisch sind mit
anderen Worten die Länder sollten ein
höheres Maß an Autonomie behalten
[Musik]
das Zauberwort heißt Subsidiarität
allgemein stellt sich einen neuen
italienischen Regierung der konservative
Block in der EU um Polen herum zumal die
fratelli wie gesagt zusammen mit der
polnischen PES der Fraktion europäische
konservative und Reformer in
EU-Parlament angehören im übrigen ist
das allerdings keine explizit Anti EU
gerichtete Fraktion wie die Identität
und Demokratie zu der die italienische
Liga salvin ist oder die deutsche AFD
gehören was die Außenpolitik angeht
werden wir hier also keine großen
Veränderungen in Italien erleben
abgesehen von gelegentlichen Reibereien
mit Brüssel etwas das unter den
Mitgliedern der Union ohne Ende immer
häufiger vorkommt aber kommen wir zu
vielleicht wichtigsten Thema melonis im
Wahlkampf dass ihr einiges an
Wählerstimmen eingebracht haben dürfte
die heiße Frage der
illegalen Einwanderung und unsere Frage
lautet nun was genau schlägt Meloni hier
eigentlich vor
nur sie verteidigt im wesentlichen drei
zentrale Ideen erstens will sie einen
Mechanismus einführen um Schiffe mit
illegalen Einwanderern aus den
italienischen Hoheit Gewässern zu
vertreiben insbesondere wenn Sie eine
NGO gehören zweitens befürwortet sie die
Einrichtung eines Netzwerks von Hotspot
in Nordafrika dort sollen Asylanträge
auch außerhalb der Europäischen Union
bearbeitet werden können sie schlägt vor
dass dieses Netzwerk von Brüssel selbst
verwaltet wird und drittens legiert Sie
dafür das Aufenthaltsgenehmigungen und
die Staatsbürgerschaft etwas anders
vergeben werden sollen als bisher die
Auswahlkriterien sollen hierbei an die
soziokulturelle Ähnlichkeit zu Italien
geknüpft werden konkret bedeutet das
Meloni will weniger muslimische
Einwanderer und mehr christliche
Lateinamerikaner und die Nationen
addiere
zum letzten Punkt dieses Videos zur
Innenpolitik
Meloni verfolgt auch hier eine starke
konservative Linie so stellt sie
besonders die jüdische christlichen
Wurzeln des Landes heraus dass diese
sogar die Sozialpolitik gestartetes
bestimmen sollten daher ist Meloni z.B
auch gegen Abtreibung sie will sie zwar
nicht ganz verbieten allerdings
Maßnahmen einführen oder die Frauen
davon abhalten zu diesen extremen Mittel
zu greifen sie ist auch gegen die
gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe die in Italien
noch nicht legal ist auf der anderen
Seite hat sie sich aber auch für die
Beibehaltung des zivilrechtlichen
Vereinigung von Homosexuellen
ausgesprochen die Leihmutterschaft für
beziehungsweise Adoption durch
gleichgeschlechtliche Paare lehnt sie
allerdings wiederum ab
[Musik]
und das alles bedeutet wir sprechen
nicht von einer relevanten Veränderung
gegenüber der aktuellen Situation in
Italien die Regierungslinie könnte
allenfalls der polnischen ähnlicher
werden und ob wir das nun gut finden
oder nicht der Punkt ist dass wir ein
wirtschaftlicher politischer und soziale
Hinsicht keine großen umweltsuche
während melonens Regierungszeit erwarten
das gewagteste könnte ihre
Wirtschaftspolitik sein und machen wir
uns nichts vor es wird wahrscheinlich
auch da keine Revolution oder ähnliches
geben es könnte viel mehr sein dass eine
lohne sich in solchen Fragen stärker den
EU Mainstream ernährt müssen sich
dadurch größere Hilfen aus Brüssel
erhofft
viele Medien haben uns die Vorstellung
vermittelt das mit Meloni die
faschistische Apokalypse über Italien
hereinbricht oder doch wenigstens eine
Marsch Richtung ultra rechts begonnen
hätte es ist jedoch sehr wahrscheinlich
dass das alles stark übertrieben ist und
denkt jetzt nicht dass wir über eine Art
von Politik sprechen die uns von
visualpolitik gefällt aber wir müssen
der Realität treu bleiben und die Kirche
in Dorf lassen aber wie dem auch sei
klar ist das Italien vor einer
komplizierten Zukunft steht das war
schon vor Meloni der Fall und hat sich
mit ihr fürs erste auch nicht geändert
zwar hat eine populistische Regierung
einem Land bisher selten wirklich gut
getan aber das wird in der kausal Meloni
erst die Zukunft zeigen und außerdem
besprechen hier immer noch von
italienischer Politik dass man abwarten
wie lange die neue Regierung unter
Meloni an der Macht bleiben kann aber
jetzt hat auf jeden Fall erstmal hier
wieder an der Reihe glaubt ihr dass die
Regierung beloni und ihre Mitte
rechtskoalition eine Radikalisierung in
der italienischen Politik bedeuten
werden oder wird Millionär vielleicht
der Anfang vom Ende der italienischen
Krise sein ist die Gefahr für die
Demokratie und die Freiheit so groß wie
einige Medien die darstellen wie immer
sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
vielleicht auch das dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gib uns bitte ein Like da sind
und Freunden und vergessliches Abo mit
Glocke um keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]